hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all the major problems of the
world so to help you on your path in
today's video we're going to talk about
seven ways to manage negative people at
work and as always guys if you're
listening if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below put quotes
around it to other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself to enjoy some of the most
difficult things about being in a work
environment is being around negative
people I think even just in home and in
general being around negative people
sucks and be able to navigate around and
with those people can sometimes be
important on your journey and so today
I'm going to share with you seven
different ways to do it that I hope will
inspire you and help you on your path my
number one way to manage negative people
is don't don't be around negative people
eliminate them from your life this is
what I try to do as much as possible in
my own life this may not be the answer
that you're looking for and there's more
than are coming but it's my best answer
because if you are surrounded by
negative people constantly you're going
to get more negative you're going to be
unhappy you're not going to reach your
potential and so if I was in a work
environment and this person was really
negative being around me all the time I
might kind of transfer I might look for
other opportunities I might even look at
a different company or maybe even
leaving instead of my own business and
being an entrepreneur if you are an
entrepreneur and you have negative
people on your teams and that's an
easier decision if somebody is really
skilled does a great job but they're
negative they have to go you can
obviously run it by negative people
because they don't only bring you down
they'll bring everybody else around you
dance and so you need to have people who
are positive who are excited about the
project that you're trying to build
[Music]
my number-two technique for managing
negative people is to limit your
exposure so if you are forced to deal
with negative people I would try to
limit how much exposure I have to them
how much time I have to spend with them
would be at the bare minimum just to get
whatever project I'm trying to do and
get it done and so the first two points
are pretty negative right it's avoid
them have zero exposure the second one
is to limit your exposure and why you
know if I'm thinking well I want to be a
positive influence I want to help them I
want to build them up yes that's
definitely a possibility the reason why
I start with a negative is because the
opportunity cost is so great for you to
spend your time managing somebody who is
negative
they will eat up so much of your time
and emotional capital and drain you
because they're so different than you
and get it into the place where they can
be happy is such a big journey that you
could spend that time helping 10 other
people and so I've always experienced
the people who are negative take the
most work to turn around and usually
it's not worth your time compared to the
other people who you could be helping
that's why my first two are really
negative around not being around them at
all or living in your exposure all right
now let's jump to the positive side
number three is being inspiration so we
have to be around these negative people
we have no other option they're super
important and we want to be the force
for good you can be an inspiration to
build people up and so I think of when
when women first get together in an
office setting eventually their periods
start to align together that kind of
happens with everything if you are
around toxic people you're more likely
to be toxic on an ongoing basis if
you're around people who are working out
all the time you're more likely to want
to work out and take care of yourself if
you're around complainers you're going
to start complaining more and so you
become your environment so if you have
that awareness you could be an
inspiration for that person by them just
being around you we are going to pull
them up I used to volunteer at a
hospital Sunnybrook Hospital here in
Toronto and one of my shifts was with
this
woman who was in charge of the phones on
her floor she would always pick up the
phone that kind of very angry ways and
see - Laura - Laura it's kind of very
angry and it was kind of against how I
would do things just a vibe I wanted to
put out and by spending more and more
time with her eventually she got more
positive to see - Laura the CTO this is
Laura speaking and it slowly got more
and more and more and more positive now
as I left Sunnybrook as my volunteer
shift ended I don't know if that
continued or she fell back to her usual
path but expect that to happen you know
the more they are around you I want you
to be a force for good right when you
find your one word whatever that is that
exudes out of you in every situation
that you go to so if you are around me
for any consistent period of time even
from watching the videos you're going to
believe harder you're going to believe
stronger in yourself and your ideas and
the people around you because that's
what I'm all about you can't be in my
circle and not gain a little bit more
belief it's just going to happen so that
should be you with your one word getting
out there and being an inspiration for
people the danger is that as I said -
people tend to come together the danger
that you become more toxic and you
become more negative so you need to have
enough other stuff in your environment
that keeps you at a high level that
pulls them to you instead of you going
to them tip number four is to come from
a place of understanding I think a lot
of people's negativity is actually
deeply rooted into something else beyond
on what they're complaining about so I
had a situation with a negative person
on my team they were constantly putting
others down they were constantly
paranoid about what the company
situation is going to be like and they
were also gossiping a lot and spreading
rumors and every single day he would
complain I would ask him how he is going
and he would say it's terrible and it
got to a point that it was actually
starting to make me feel negative about
my situation at work and then finally I
have a sit-down conversation with him I
wanted to find out why he was being so
negative then he revealed to me that he
was paranoid of losing his job she would
wake up every morning
with a fear that he won't be able to
feed his family he will not be able to
go on that vacation that he promised his
wife although I wasn't able to promise
him the job security that he wanted I
was able to provide him with the
security and safety that he had someone
at work that he could confide and little
by little I started to see more
positivity come out of him especially
towards me which made my life at work a
lot easier so the next time you come
across someone negative before you write
them off try to come from a place of
understanding number five is figure out
their dream I like to say that one of
the most dangerous things you can do is
tell me what your dream is if I know
what your dream is then I am always
thinking about how do I help this person
get this thing that they want to do and
pushing you to get past those limiting
beliefs and the negative mindsets to
help you go off and accomplish your big
thing and so even the most negative
person has some kind of dream they may
not feel as possible they may feel like
the world's against them and that people
conspiring to keep them down but
somewhere deep down inside they have a
dream of something that they want to
accomplish and so if you can figure out
what their dream is and then find ways
to help them accomplish it be their
friend be their accountability partner
give them some resources give them some
motivational boost share things with
them to help them lift up and get
towards that goal then it's really hard
to be making progress towards your dream
and being negative I'm happy at the same
time and so guiding them along that path
and encouraging them will help turn that
tide and turn them from being super
negative to a more positive number six
has recognized their good behavior this
is basic parenting skills or if you are
trying to train a dog it's kind of the
same thing you have two options you
either punish their bad behavior or you
recognize their good behavior and you
may not be in a position to punish them
for their bad behaviors and it may be
actually what they want because they
seek the attention they love going to a
negative place and so I would deal with
that kind of person I had to deal with
them then I'd be looking at the negative
stuff I'm just going to ignore and
anytime there is
something positive that they do for me
or the mindset that they have or
something that they shared that was
happy or funny or positive I would go
all in on encouraging that and thank
them and appreciate them not in a fake
way not in the way that they see
obviously right through but in a genuine
way of you really connecting to that
thing that they did for you and thanking
them maybe buying them you know a little
cupcake or something as a show of
appreciation because negative people
aren't surrounded by a lot of positivity
in generals how they become so negative
and so by you recognizing the good deeds
that they did giving us an appreciation
giving them some rewards they're going
to want to do it again and again and
again and lift out of that negativity
[Music]
and my number seven way to deal with
negative people is help them find a
happier place quite often negative
people are so bummed out by their
position by their work they're not
passionate about it anymore they don't
you know have that desire to be there
anymore and everybody would be happier
if they moved on it kind of cries a
little bit into understanding what their
dream is because often if they have a
dream and they're doing something
totally different then they're going to
be negative and unhappy they're going to
see other people who are off
accomplishing these great things in the
field that they want to be in and
they're stuck in this job that they hate
and so helping push them to follow that
dream find a happier place go pursue
that passion is great for them because
they're happier they're off doing the
thing that they need and sometimes then
you just need a little bit of a push and
it's great for you because now you don't
have to deal with this negative person
in your work environment anymore so
those are my top seven ways and how to
manage negative people at work I'd love
to know what did you guys think what was
your favorite one which one really hit
home what can you apply to your business
or maybe your life immediately leave it
down the comments below did I miss an
eight nine ten that you guys want to add
to the list I'm really curious to find
out I made this video because Louise
Torelli asked me to so the topic you'd
like me to cover in a future 7 way
series check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Frodo from the actualised youtube
channel thank you so much rain for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing the review on your
channel
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm still
glad that you love the book so thank you
guys for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon